So good news
for those who have the participation
and interest in their company,
since it will be possible to unlock 1 game
in deux-mille-vingt-quatre
as had been the case in deux-mille-vingt-deux.
We watch this together.
So for those who have already benefited
in deux-mille-vingt-deux,
it will be about the same conditions.
So as a reminder,
it was to protect the purchasing power of the French
and especially after Covid.
So in order to benefit from it,
employees will have to respect certain conditions.
So you will have to apply already
before the thirty-first of December deux-mille-vingt-quatre.
So the withdrawal will be capped at €10.000
and it must be done only once.
And therefore the unlockable amounts must be paid
or present on your business departure plan
before January 1st deux-mille-vingt-quatre,
that is, if you perform
1 payment on
your business departure plan in March
deux-mille-vingt-quatre
for example,
this will not be taken into account in this measure.
It remains to be seen whether this release will replace
in deux-mille-vingt-quatre
will be as successful as in deux-mille-vingt-deux.
For information,
1,2000000000 euros have been withdrawn
in deux-mille-vingt-deux by the French